quando sono arrivato a torino ormai
dieci anni fa ho scoperto che torino era
una città davvero bellissima
era una città piena di cultura era una
città in cui c'erano dei luoghi
fantastici da visitare ed uno di questi
luoghi in particolare è diventato un
appuntamento fisso l'appuntamento fisso
del sabato mattina
sto parlando del baloon il balloon è un
luogo magico un luogo in cui si
incrociano storie culture persone è un
luogo anche dove ho comprato un sacco di
oggetti impensabili ed ogni sabato
tornavo a casa con un nuovo oggetto
improbabile che mettevo nella mia stanza
ad un certo punto la stanza è diventata
troppo piccola
perché gli oggetti erano davvero troppi
in quella stanza così ho chiesto aiuto a
mio fratello architetto e gli ho chiesto
ma perché non costruiamo un letto a
soppalco
dopo tre giorni avevo il mio nuovo letto
a soppalco
era bellissimo grande e comodo di design
c'era un unico problema l'interruttore
per spegnere la luce era davvero lontano
da quel letto ogni sera prima di andare
a letto
dovevo semplicemente spegnere la luce e
poi andare a dormire puntualmente ogni
sera ero a letto e dimenticavo di
spegnere la luce
dovevo quindi scendere spegnere la luce
e tornare a letto questa sera è andata
avanti per qualche mese
ricordo che una sera pensavo beh sarebbe
davvero interessante poter spegnere
questa luce dal mio smartphone collegare
in qualche modo quell'interruttore
fisico che dovevo toccare per forza con
il dito al mio cellulare
così ho pensato di mettere a frutto in
qualche modo quegli anni di studi
io avevo fatto al politecnico e quindi
ho progettato un dispositivo che fosse
abbastanza piccolo da poter essere
inserito all'interno delle cassette
elettriche e proprio fianco agli
interruttori fisici ma quello stesso
oggetto avrebbe permesso
all'interruttore fisico di essere
controllato dal mio smartphone solo poco
dopo mi sono reso conto che in quello
stesso momento non avevo risolto il mio
problema di spegnere le luci dal letto
ma avevo risolto il problema di
tantissime persone che da sempre hanno
sognato di avere una casa smart ma non
l'hanno mai fatto perché oggi è un
processo difficile e costoso spesso
richiede una completa ristrutturazione
tutta la casa
io invece partendo da quell'interruttore
e dandogli l'intelligenza con un
dispositivo ero riuscito a collegarlo al
mio smartphone
oggi questo dispositivo qui è diventato
il mio lavoro e oggi abbiamo inserito
tutti questi dispositivi all'interno
delle luci di scena e nello spirito di
te dx in particolare di questo evento
nello spirito di cooperazione di questo
evento the licks torino con scenografie
remo tutti quanti insieme
tutto questo evento perciò vi chiedo a
tutti i 50 tra il pubblico che hanno
ricevuto la possibilità durante il check
in di controllare le luci di scena di
accendere i vostri cellulari aprire
l'app che vi è stata data e dimostrare i
cellulari a tutto il pubblico per farvi
identificare grazie ad esso chiedo per
favore alla regia di spegnere tutte
queste luci
e chiedo voi del pubblico che potete
azionare queste luci di scena di
accendere la luce numero uno
bene c'è qualcuno con la luce 5 e 4 e
questa luce due ci siamo quasi
ok vedo la luce uno accesa c'è qualcun
altro che però si sta divertendo quella
luce due
ecco alla luce quattro ok accendiamo la
luce due adesso accendiamo la luce tre
sì la luce 4 è la luce 5
[Musica]
adesso complichiamo un pochino il gioco
adesso accendiamo la luce 5 meno 35 meno
tre dai ci siamo 5 meno 3 è facile no
c'è ancora qualche indeciso sul 3 15 sul
4 5
stiamo facendo 5 meno 3 il risultato di
5 mentre è semplice
ok la maggior parte ci è arrivata siamo
a due
qualcuno dice 3
[Risate]
vabbè facciamo a maggioranza siamo a 25
mila 32 ottimo ok completiamo ancora un
attimino le cose
passiamo a 2x2
accendiamo la luce ci siamo ci siamo
quasi tutta dai agli ultimi indecisi
sulla luiss numero due per 24 se
qualcuno ci ripensi a qualcuno che passa
al 2 siamo alla 4 la maggioranza ha
detto 42 per 24 ottimo e andiamo avanti
[Applauso]
adesso accendiamo le luci 24 24 2 e 4 2
e 4 ottimo mi hanno capito il gioco bene
e adesso molto semplice adesso
accendiamo le luci radici di quadrata di
152 milioni 399 mila a zero 25
il pubblico di domande o che forse
abbiamo andati un po oltre
torniamo con una cosa più semplice
radice quadrata di 9 13 quadrata di non
è cieco come indeciso su quattro secondo
me qua 4 al quadrato 9 è un po strettino
vero forse qualcuno dice 23
molti dicono 3 ok perfetto tutti
d'accordo radici parlano di nome siamo a
3 2 a 0 ora accendiamo 2 a 0 chi si
ricorda contro fa 20 ragazzi ci siamo
quasi eccezionale 2 la zerouno
fantastici
[Applauso]
va bene comunque ragazzi la radice
quadrata di 152 milioni 399 mila a zero
25 era facile dai la radice quadrata di
questo numero è semplicemente 12345 1 2
3 4 e 5
va bene ragazzi è stato bellissimo
adesso scatenatevi fate voi la
scenografia accendete spegnete queste
luci come volete
grazie a tutti
[Applauso]